Democrats are celebrating their first
victories in the era of President Trump
wins in the gubernatorial races in
Virginia and New Jersey and contests
elsewhere across the country they've
declared Election Day 2017 a referendum
on the president you have sent a message
tonight not simply to the voters in the
Commonwealth of Virginia you have sent a
message across the globe to South Korea
Donald Trump you don't stand for our
values you made a choice for better
schools for better jobs for better
education and better health care and you
rejected Donald Trump's fear hatred and
bigotry this is one of the first major
elections since Donald Trump was elected
tonight New Jersey sent an unmistakable
message to the entire nation we are
better than this this was a rejection
not only a president Trump but of the
policies that he and the Republican
Party seemed to be adopting president
Trump sees it otherwise though he was
unable to help draw more votes for
Virginia Republican and Gillespie he
tweeted Gillespie worked hard but did
not embrace me or what I stand for
don't forget Republicans won four out of
four House seats and with the economy
doing record numbers we will continue to
win even bigger than before so let me
clarify no Gregg I didn't burp at the
beginning it's like sometimes your need
to swallow before you talk but then all
of a sudden like we're on and then that
guy was like oh my gosh it's just that
guys with four clumps just lack of
professionalism that's a certainty there
are people that tuned in for real real
TV here you burp and start with real and
it's okay we'll go to Kimberly first
[Applause]
I'd really Greg you should learn
something from this I've done so
obviously this was a bit of an upset
right because there was yes he was down
to saying three percent but it was
within the margin of error so you
thought okay maybe he can pull it out
because he had the momentum okay then he
got the endorsement from President Trump
so anyway he's slicing he got to be
honest this was you know disappointing
because they would really hoped to kind
of turn this around when you look at the
map you saw Wow read read read read read
but some of the bigger cities and those
urban areas the suburbs and we've seen
that happen right in New York etc
anywhere you've got a few key places
cities that are more urban that actually
pull in the large majority of votes
despite the fact that the whole rest of
the map was red so fascinating from that
point cuz we've seen a bit of a trend
you know in that direction and we
certainly did the presidential election
and then I thought it was kind of
interesting what Trump kind of backed
away a little bit saying well you
weren't enough like I am so therefore
you didn't get it across the finish line
well there was a lot of analysis going
back and forth on that what do you think
of it
I don't necessarily believe the Trump
tweet but it was great spin I'll give
him that I think a Democrat won blue
state last night no time to panic but
there are some serious warning signs
they're wearing a blue tie today I know
well it's just playing mind games with
the left camera so and we're gonna be
going to the scream fest later when they
all yell and when how angry they are
about the election I want to be
undercover yeah so look at Virginia I
don't think the last three presidential
elections a Republican has won that
state there's a lot of government
employees there a larger Hispanic
population and very wealthy zip codes
Virginia was never Trump country Donald
Trump peeked out the primary win over
Rubio and then lost it by five points to
Hillary Clinton the new Virginia
governor as Gregg pointed out the other
day is a two-time George W Bush voter
not a member of the resistance and a
Navy veteran and the Democrats have not
won anything on red territory yet let's
be honest this was not on enemy
territory this was their home turf I so
let's pump the brakes on the DEM wave at
the same time I think in 2008 or 9 after
Obama was in the sand
position Republicans had one New Jersey
Massachusetts and Virginia so let's just
slow down now they're awarding science
Trump's approval rating in Virginia
forty percent that's not very good
turnout among Democrats was very very
high and it was an anti-trump vote it
wasn't a Pro Northam vote and they did
very well as Kimberly said the Democrats
among suburban people especially
college-educated whites especially
college-educated women and the
Republicans got trounced in the state
legislature races which means the
grassroots movement is there there is a
concern though a narratives remember how
Obama did so well when he was on the
ticket but then when he was off the
ticket he got trounced so the warning
sign is because of trumps loyal base and
he's a persona driven movement that when
he's not there in a midterm or an
off-year election the people aren't
going to turnout and it's gonna be an
anti-trump vote as part of that though
Greg was because Obama pretty much
didn't worry about it he he just let the
party kind of do it it was he was like
the party of one and that's one of the
reasons that they've had to try to claw
their way back yeah I think this is it's
this is completely natural the pendulum
swing we saw this under Obama's the
opposition is always more galvanized
when they are out of power they have
every reason to go out there and vote
and and it's more exciting to vote for
President Obama than his party and it
was more exciting to vote for Donald
Trump than his party so that's what you
see you need the gala you need a focal
point which was President Obama and
Donald Trump but it's oddly it's like a
natural set of checks and balances you
elect this guy Donald Trump and then you
let the other side gate seats by not
voting it's almost like unconsciously
it's some kind of evolutionary reflex
that we crave the tension between
parties we want to have this guy in but
we don't want to go too far so we almost
unconsciously decide not to reduc not to
put anything out there until we have to
so did you get this weird kind of Bounce
but I want to talk about just one more
thing if Edie Gillespie had won one
would have said this was a harbinger a
bitter hateful camp
but now these ugly these ugly ads that
go after sanctuary city laws this is
going to be the norm because ed
gillespie one ralph one that's an
ominous sign that bitter hateful
identity political politics ads with
because that ad that we trashed worked
yeah he ad to portrayed white people as
white Republicans as racist who killed
children it actually worked when you
talk when Tom Perez talks about fear
hatred and bigotry he's talking about
his own party they this should send a
chill up everybody's spine if he's still
got a spine that this is dangerous stuff
that that did the company that did that
ad already claimed they're gonna do it
ignore gonna that phrase but they're
gonna double down in it so the idea that
somehow you know and they did something
really really ugly and it works I think
that they would have done that ad
against Edie even if he had not run ads
about ms-13 yeah because I think that
that is that they'll probably will
they'll try to run that play again and
again and one will give you the floor
here in a second I just want to point
out that married women had gone for
President Trump in Virginia by like a
point over
Ralph Northam one married women by ten
points over egg Elizabeth but still
Gillespie got 120,000 more Republican
votes in 2017 than he did in 2014 when
he ran for the Senate so it was a high
turnout election all across the board
but the Democrats certainly had a lot
more votes they did have a lot more
votes and I you know to me it has all
the markings of a wave election going
back if you look at what happened in oh
six when the Democrats took over the
House of Representatives and you go then
forward remember that when you remember
that well to ten when the Republicans
took over the house from the Democrats
and so what we saw in both cases is very
similar what we saw here in Virginia but
nationwide last night and so then you
look at things like now the generic
number in terms of preference
Republicans Democrats for the House of
Representatives is double digits at the
moment for the Democrats and then factor
in what Greg was talking about in terms
of trumps approval rating at the moment
I think Gallup hasn't about thirty eight
percent this does not help especially
you consider that historically the part
yes you said that I'm sorry okay so they
are different people want I know not to
hear it except the father when you
consider that when you the president
who's in power is not popular it
historically hurts in the midterms now
yeah I think the the big points that I
took away from last night the big issue
was not immigration not at all
the big issue number one issue health
care not even close forty percent of
voters that it was their number one
issue and they favored northern the
Democrat by fifty five percent
Wow now you factor in what happened in
Maine where you had Maine voters go
against their governor and say you know
what we want to expand Medicaid oh my
gosh this is the first time that
Obamacare has been expanded by a general
elect a referendum if you will general
vote of the people and again it says a
lot about what could be the big issues
going into 18 and the other thing that I
would throw in here is that for the
Democrats the reason they are so
exuberant is they can now they're going
to see a boost in fundraising in
candidates ray Ben Lujan who runs the
house democratic election card he's
saying you know what I'm calling people
all night people are calling me back
that's unbelievable all of a sudden
Democrats who've been lagging a fine
that they have some energy so I think
this is good news can I bring in
somebody who was not on the ballot but
was on people's minds and it's Hillary
Clinton who'd let said that last night
was a great reminder of what's possible
when we come together and fight for what
we believe in so I wanted to take a few
minutes to celebrate the extraordinary
successes of a few groups I and onward
together proudly fight alongside and yet
Kimberly yeah well what do you think of
that because she's not I think that the
Democrats are a little bit more
liberated now that they don't have her
as like ended it albatross hanging
choking the very life out of the neck of
the party yeah I mean so of course she's
trying to like you know bootstrap onto
this and say you know this is the
movement this is what look what I do
like she's the face of it look what
happened now that I've been back out
Rose talking about the Rosie Ruiz of
politics
knock into thee as the marathon was
ending she's she's pretending she's
leading the parade it's unbelievable but
you know people see through it they see
through it so of course she wants to be
placed wants to give some
congratulations but this really doesn't
have anything to do with her no it's all
about Trump I mean that's I don't know
if that's good news to you guys but it's
kind of curious because it was like 60%
some places what do you mean well
meaning that like I think Virginia is
just a tough place for Republicans going
forward I do think that it's as Jesse
asked me before is it no longer a purple
state and I think it is like Virginia
Democrat won in New Jersey I mean
everyone was surprised when Chris
Christie won there I mean it's a blue
state lon
Virginia's blue I'm too excited about
the wave I remember it's still right now
a little trickle well let me just say
that I think that when you're not when
you look at the map that Kimberly was
describing you see all that red in the
middle and these are mostly there's not
that many people that live there
yeah that's let's put it that way but I
will say this that 60% of the people who
voted said they had a negative in
Virginia negative impression GOP and 60%
said they have a negative impression of
guess who Donald Trump and but a lot of
market to democratic party approval
rating is it a historic low let's all
keep an eye on Governor Terry McAuliffe